celebrating young Hollywood tonight how
does it feel I love young Hollywood it's
my favorite version of Hollywood young
yes the young side did you ever think
when you started doing YouTube videos
that you'd be here no I was just
thinking it this is like so crazy even
the fact that I can like see the
Hollywood sign from like where I'm
standing is insane to me so this is I
don't even have words to put this into
because it's so confusing just gonna get
crazier because you're also hosting the
Teen Choice Awards yeah what do you have
up your sleeve I genuinely have nothing
I hope people don't expect me be crazy
cuz I I don't know I'm so nervous the
only thing I have up my sleeve is just
nerves and a whole bunch of sweat
because I'm so scared
Taylor Swift she's gonna be there she's
being honored I don't know I feel like
I'll get tackled if I even come near her
so I don't I don't know what I'm gonna
do
no it is crazy that they're allowing me
in the same area as her I don't know I
mean I guess the possibilities are
endless but I think I'm gonna i'ma play
it cool
can you do me a favor and get this scoop
from her on the new album yeah what's
the scoop what do you need to know find
out like the tracklist for us of course
I'm happy belated birthday - thank you
best gift you got from your friends best
gift
they helped me film like a lot the
entire week like like a lot more than
they normally do so I really appreciate
it that yeah Tanna and Jake sure what's
the question I've been asked this before
okay is it a forever thing of course not
no I'd be surprised if it last another
three days do you think that your
marriage is gonna last longer well I
already got divorced yeah I knew you
guys were what a month we were a month
in yeah and but we ended on good terms I
don't know if Tana and Jake have that in
them and so similarly like we did drama
or what's with why do you say that no I
think they're just too young and too
crazy to stay with each other yeah I
think they're both lunatics in a good
way and I think they won't be able to
handle each other is it a real
relationship you know people have been
questioning I actually think they I
actually think they get along yeah but I
mean I'm sure they're gonna ask you oh
it's real no did someone say that like
they looked it up and like the papers I
can't believe I'm going into like such
detail I was doing Myron yeah like I
think someone looked it up and like they
didn't have marriage papers I don't know
it doesn't matter because at the end of
day it's so entertaining and like the
fact that you're even talking about it
means they got their job done so they're
killing it you are you looking for love
are you looking to get married anytime
soon again yeah this is it I mean this
is tonight is I'm going to find love
here yeah yeah Megan told me no I'm just
I'm so tired that the only I'm looking
for is a comfortable bed and a nice
pillow that's that's on the top of my
agenda yeah you're about to be a huge
Nickelodeon star you have this new show
what's that experience tonight yeah
we're doing America's most musical
family I normally never have anything to
talk about this is exciting lots of
things to talk to you about I could go
all night ya know it's it's so cool so
it's a show and they're basically
there's a bunch of families and they
it's it's like American Idol meets only
families and they're all so so talented
and it's all kinds of genres of music
you know pop you have polka you got all
kinds of music hip hop and it's just a
bunch of like siblings there's like
triplets there's like these huge duo's
and they're just such talented kids in
it so fun watching and I'm the judge
which kind of is computer it's cool yeah
but I don't know much about music so I
feel a little out of place but I'm
having so much
good lies that give you any advice she's
on the Nickelodeon Nickelodeon advise
yeah just to clean up my act well no I
think that's what everyone told me oh I
think what we love about you is that
you're unfiltered and you I gotta be
careful when it comes to Nickelodeon we
got gypped oh yeah yeah I'm I haven't I
haven't messed up on set yet I'm pretty
impressed let you go Olivia Jade back
with her boyfriend is a good thing and
not a good thing
yeah which boyfriend her boyfriend I
don't know they weren't held in hand I
hope it's a good thing I've never seen
anybody get back with her boyfriend it's
a bad thing I'm sure I'm sure she's
happy I don't know yeah I mean I yeah we
keep it touched but I haven't I haven't
talked to her about our boyfriend so I
don't know I I will get the scoop and
I'll let you know give you a lot of
chores today yeah you me I have to I
have homework to do I have to go home
now I'm not even doing any more
interviews because I'll forget what you
asked me so how I feel get back down
first Olivia and Taylor yeah and Taylor
okay great I got it all right thank you
so much